Transcriber: TED Translators Admin
Reviewer:
Did you know that there is a global
experiment performed
on approximately 1.6 billion people
across 75 countries twice a year?
It’s called daylight saving time.
[Sleeping with Science]
The sleep-associated consequences
are more significant than you may realize.
For example in the spring,
when we lose one hour of sleep,
there is a subsequent 24 percent
relative increase in heart attacks.
In contrast, in the fall --
in the autumn,
when we gain an hour of sleep,
there is a 21 percent reduction
in heart attacks.
Isn’t that incredible?
And I should also note
that we see similar changes
in things such as road traffic accidents,
strokes
and, tragically, suicide rates as well.
In fact, even the economy suffers
with certain stock market returns
taking a downswing
following the shift
to daylight saving time
and that one hour of lost sleep.
This is how fragile our brains,
our bodies
and even our societies are
when it comes to sleep loss.
But said more positively,
even just small increases in sleep
can have immediate
as well as long-term health benefits.
So rather than thinking
of sleep as a cost,
we can instead think of sleep
as one of the very best
investments we can make.